in Northern Gaza the battle over javal
and Shaya continues as this news
anchor it follows with images of air
strikes and military operations
targeting terrorists it
says a journalist embedded with the
Israeli military in Gaza has a clear
message for his
audience we are here deep in the Gaza
Strip with our dear forces when you see
them on the ground you'll know that we
have nothing to worry
[Music]
about 3 months into the war Israeli
media convey a patriotic message to the
population but there is a side of the
story that is clearly
missing when you watch the news in
Israel there's hardly any pictures of
the humanitarian crisis in Gaza or the
civilian casualties the main focus
continues to be what happened on October
the 7th the captives and the military
operations in
Gaza Israel is trying to recover from
the October 7th attacks and the fear it
has generated among the people here we
lost our confidence in our army in our
institutions in our leaders in the state
and the Israeli media has kept us locked
in to October 7th Israeli Society has
not moved to October 8th we're still in
October
7th but there are reports on Israeli
soldiers lost in the war and the names
of the Palestinian Fighters killed but
not the tens of thousands of Palestinian
civilian victims analysts say the media
is also playing its part it's not
something that is coming from the
government that is telling the uh the
media don't do that it's
self H volunteered by the media you know
we have toas made a massacre and we are
not going to show the casualties the
Palestinian casuals because it the
interest of
Hamas around half of the Israeli
population is estimated to get their
news from TV channels they're also
websites for newspapers and magazines
gam Basin says the coverage has a big
impact on how Israelis see the war as
Israelis don't see the Palestinian side
we're living in this tiny piece of land
between the Jordan River and the
Mediterranean Sea and we see entirely
different pictures of
reality a reality that has also left
thousands of Palestinians dead and that
for now most Israeli media have chosen
to
ignore there is a Al ja West
Jerusalem make sure to subscribe to our
channel to get the latest news from Al
jazer